drip
drip
drip
it's springtime in the pacific northwest
how delightful
it's often said
by me
that if you can't make it in silicon
valley then you head to seattle
and if you can't make it there you go to
vancouver
there's a reason housing prices are only
mildly insane in these parts
as opposed to totally insane in silicon
valley
you have to put up with things like
weather
jeff bezos's big silver
spheres
and tourist spots where people throw
fish
at your face
still as a californian i'm willing to
concede that the pacific northwest might
have some merits
i mean this is decent
and this pizza designed by a wizard
probably tastes pretty good
and so i have set out on a road trip
from seattle to vancouver
to find out why people choose to live
here
why they have given their souls over to
microsoft and amazon
and why they're so open about caging
humans in machines like this
just so they can build our dead-eyed
replacements
[Music]
tourists would probably start their trip
hanging out in seattle
[Music]
but i'm a tech dork with a time lapse to
make
and so we're going to head east to
redmond and bellevue
also known as the towns that microsoft
built
microsoft's headquarters in redmond has
all the we're doing technology
essentials
there are slogans
and more slogans
there's a garage placed randomly inside
of an office because startups come from
garages
there are buildings
and more buildings
and there are tree houses where
engineers go to meditate on how to next
level excel
and how to let skype keep languishing
nearby bellevue is similar but kind of
ritzier
this for example is the shopping mall in
the bad part of town
i have come to bellevue to see this
thing
[Music]
but mostly to meet the man who paid for
it how are you man great how are you
doing
nathan
yeah likewise
nathan is the former chief technology
officer at microsoft
today he's perhaps best known as the
world's most curious human
this is a microscope that i built
these are commercial microscopes that
are then heavily modified
and this is a solar telescope
you can see
incredible amounts of detail of the sun
churning
now this device here is a panorama robot
i use this for taking landscape pictures
and this is a four camera array that we
built
this goes onto this mount here and that
mount
slowly goes across the sky at night so
you attract the stars
so what we see are these wonderful long
meteors that nathan really does do a bit
of everything
and he does everything to the extreme
he's an accomplished paleontologist
and has dug up numerous dinosaur
skeletons
but just finding the bones is not enough
so
back in 1997
uh i was interested in the following
question which is
there are a bunch of the dinosaurs
called sauropod dinosaurs which had
really long skinny necks so apatosaurus
also called brontosaurus sometimes is an
example they also had really long skinny
tails
and a british biomechanics expert he
wondered if they could have been used to
make noise
so i made a computer model that showed
that in fact the tail of these sauropod
dinosaurs could actually act like a whip
a bull whip
now the way a bull whip makes that
cracking noise
is
because the tip of the whip actually
goes about twice the speed of sound okay
and that crack is a sonic boom
so i published a paper on this in 1997.
it was well received but also
controversial
a lot of
dinosaur paleontologists said
well i won't believe it until you build
a physical model i said okay you want a
physical model make a physical model
so
this
replicates the tail
of a apatosaurus
and so the idea is as this animal would
walk
this very long very thin tail could be
made to whip around
[Music]
we have a high speed video camera we
have shown with that high-speed video
camera that this went mach 2.
do they think it's like a defense thing
or like to make noise to signal
well okay so it turns out
half of the specimens of this kind of
dinosaur have intervertebral damage at
about number 23 somewhere down here
it turns out that same area is the area
where a bull whip wears out so
about half the specimens were whipping
their tails
so often that they damaged their bones
which totally sounds like male behavior
to me
[Laughter]
i think the way they got a date was to
impress the females by making loud booms
and if you do a scaling argument you can
show that the noise would have been
deafening
like as loud as the big guns on the uss
new jersey
so here's the other interesting thing
about wild animals
you can't know for sure what you're
going to get
nathan also likes to photograph wildlife
i decided i wanted to photograph all of
the wild cats and wild dogs in the world
well all the species not
the individuals yeah
so this is a camera trap so this is a
camera that you set up and you leave out
there and it gets automatically
triggered if the animal walks by
that's really great for
really shy animals and unfortunately
most wild cats are really shy
and this is a rig that we call the three
amigos
so we have three 600 millimeter lenses
we have wired them together with
electronics box that we built
so with this i can take a picture which
will simultaneously be taken by all
three cameras and that allows me to make
a big panorama i see sure of a moving
subject okay
so
these are sandhill cranes
there's tens of thousands of them in
this one photo
you couldn't get a picture like this
without that rig
and nathan is into snowflakes as well
like really into snowflakes
most of the water that we consume
causes snow
the reason we get any water at all in
the summer in the northwest is because
the snowpack is melting
and i'd done a lot of microscopy so oh
this is great i'll just i'll take some
pictures of snowflakes well it turns out
that's really hard
[Music]
so
after lots of experimentation and effort
we built this
so you have to you have to catch the
snowflake and
here's how you catch a snowflake
this
is a very delicate
sable brush
and you put this down and as it gets
close to the snowflake
static electricity makes the snowflake
jump up and it touches that and then
it's in here and then we put it on here
and we have to put it on a slide that's
made out of artificial sapphire
then we have our lighting rig made with
an exotic set of light emitting diodes
which were able to pulse very very fast
then we have a computer-controlled
mechanism and it takes a series of
pictures quickly
so this is some of the results
and these are actually the highest
resolution photographs of snowflakes
ever taken
on our first snowflake shoot when the
first one came out
i i turned to my two compatriots who
were with me i said look i don't know
how great this is going to be going
forward but we definitely have our
christmas cards
these days nathan spends a lot of his
time in the kitchen
he's an accomplished chef who has
produced a stunning series of cookbooks
called modernist cuisine
the books are famous for how big they
are
their amazing photos
[Music]
and the science and techniques they
describe
nathan's most recent book centers on
pizza
well pizza is the probably the single
most popular dish on earth the other
thing about pizza is that there's tons
of lore and legend and oh you you can't
make pizza unless you have the water of
naples yeah
your oven was constructed of special
stone quarry near naples or those sorts
of myths and legends are one of the
things that we love to dig into because
sometimes it's a germ of truth to it in
which case it's really interesting and
in other cases it's just hooey
so this is our pizza scanner okay so it
turns out there's different things you
can do in the crust on different
techniques of baking that'll make the
rim either puffier or less puffy okay
well i wanted to measure that
so it's putting a structured light field
on it very much like a lidar in a
self-driving car okay
and this one this is for stretching so
this is a called a texture analyzer okay
what this does is it presses on a
subject and it measures the force as it
presses
and so you get a force versus
displacement curve
and from that curve you can tell the
crispiness or chewiness
what else do we have we've got a
centrifuge and what what do you use this
for
so here
is
ground up peas okay so this is frozen
peas from the supermarket and we puree
them into goo
well then when you spin them in the
centrifuge
you get
this and you can like extract that out
and make that this concentrated sort of
essence and it's fantastic
and then this is called a rotary
evaporator rotary evaporators are
basically used for distillation so we've
got some tomatoes that we have ground up
it spins in here and we suck a vacuum
and then we carefully cool it and that
allows us to concentrate it and here is
the concentrate so
i would
invite you to taste some
should taste like a fresh tomato
wow
yeah nathan's pizza pal is francisco
magoya
he's a world-class pastry chef who used
to work at french laundry i'm gonna make
a couple pizzas for you to see there's
gonna we're gonna
do not classical toppings on them as
well so that you can see more or less
kind of science the science the [ __ ] out
of this pizza okay
actually hannah's adobo
so it's got to be very supple but it's
also very light
that's because we've allowed it to
slowly build up the gas in it we always
ferment overnight in a refrigerator okay
uh it makes a huge huge difference
so it really should be very supple you
can see how francisco is working on that
yeah
so we're basically trying to stretch
this without making it too thin either
we're trying to leave also a bit of a
rim yeah because this is going to puff
up when it bakes
this is basically an alfredo sauce that
you would typically put on pasta
favorites and this is a smoked paprika
mozzarella fresh mozzarella okay
yeah we made a whole set of our own
flavored mozzarellas
all right so i'm gonna go in the oven
now okay
how hot is it this is at 8 40. 840.
so there you have it smells amazing so
this is ibericohem
we also did the pea butter that's what
we put on top and some pea shoots
okay well let's try some
it's delicious
i like kind of the
saltiness of the ham and the with the
the pea
and that's like the best crust i think
i've ever had i mean so light yeah
there's so much uh flavor in there
time for another one yes please
okay
so here we have an ingredient called
pressure caramelized zucchini
we've pressure cooked it and we've added
some baking soda
and the reason is the reactions that
cause food to brown
a chemist would say it was the my yard
reaction
so if you add some baking soda and
pressure cook the zucchini the natural
sugars and zucchini will mire dies
and that puts a unique flavor in it okay
it's really good
you're not gonna
you have no motivation like open a pizza
place or so my usual joke is a as a
cookbook writer i'm familiar with one
capital intensive often money losing
business i don't need to be in a second
one
but if you're passionate and curious
about pizza you will learn all kinds of
things in the book you'll find nowhere
else were there some things you
discovered that were
that were kind of myths about oh
the water that you use to make a pizza
we made pizza with water from a swimming
pool
now i don't recommend that you use
swimming pool water
but
it worked didn't kill the yeast
away from the kitchen nathan heads up
intellectual ventures
it's a very controversial company that
hires very bright people to think up
ideas
like people literally sit in a room and
think up inventions
and then intellectual ventures patents
the ideas
nathan says he does this to let ideas
flourish
other people say he's a patent troll
because he's trying to collect as many
big ideas as possible so that iv can
charge people for access to them
so there were a bunch of tech companies
particularly large tech companies
that had the attitude of look if we want
to use ideas in our products
that's our prerogative
you know who the hell are you inventor
yeah all you did was come up with the
idea yeah you know i think that
if you create a situation where
big tech companies can steal any
invention they want to that's not right
it's just it's morally not right but i
think it's also
less efficient at getting new ideas for
the world yeah
so you you actually were born in seattle
but grew up in southern california yeah
that's right my uh my joke is that i'm
like a salmon i had to come back to the
home stream to spawn
i know by the time you were 14 i think
you already skipped four grades and
graduated high school and you're heading
off to college
you pursued
a couple fields of very hardcore science
i have a bachelor's degree
a master's a second masters and a phd
and they're all in different topics but
the last one was physics
and
i was a postdoc with stephen hawking at
cambridge
and then i wound up starting a software
company in 1983.
then microsoft acquired our company
then we went to work for bill gates
so you're not a computer scientist by
training you get to microsoft you end up
as the chief technology officer but then
you have all these interests clearly as
you know we can see so is that what was
bubbling inside of you was just this
need to go off and try you know go
explore all these things that you're
fascinated by and
i loved my time at microsoft but i did
have to put
90 percent of my waking time into one
thing
uh and i am naturally interested in lots
of other things
one of the biggest things you have
pursued at intellectual ventures and
through sort of your friendship and
various partnerships with bill gates a
lot of it's around climate change and
technology
related to that
you've had big ideas around
geoengineering and i've seen you guys
talk about the
filling the atmosphere with particles to
well so here's here's a way to think
about global warming
[Music]
sunlight leaves the sun it comes roaring
across the 93 million miles of space it
hits earth some of it then is
re-radiated as infrared radiation
and then for radiation comes up and it
hits co2 in the atmosphere and it gets
stuck that's what global warming is
about
well the amount of energy the sun is
depositing here on earth is about 300
watts per square meter the amount of
extra radiation that is trapped by this
extra co2 in our atmosphere is somewhere
being two and three watts per square
meter it's one percent
so it's a little effect but of course it
compounds across all of earth and then
it keeps building up over time and
that's what eventually screws you
well
that means one approach to this is we
just have to make the sun one percent
dimmer
well how do you control the sun
the answer is you could control that by
putting particles in the high atmosphere
and
human eyes really aren't sensitive to a
one percent change you need almost a
factor of two change in light for us to
see a difference
so if we bounce that off
you literally couldn't tell here on
earth that you've done it
there's another set of ideas that are
about how you could capture co2 directly
out of the atmosphere
[Music]
many parts of the ocean are very
nutrient poor
they're nutrient poor primarily because
they lack iron
so you can do something called iron
fertilization
you put dissolved iron similar to what a
human would take for an iron supplement
if you're anemic and you put that into
the sea water and immediately enormous
amounts of plankton bloom
those blooming plankton feed lots of
fish so you help the whole ecosystem
that way
but then quite a bit of those plankton
die and they fall down to the bottom of
the ocean carrying their carbon with
them
i mean i think the general idea probably
that a lot of people have is we do
something like that
just
by nature of being humans we're gonna up
even worse somehow you know well
maybe it turns out that geoengineering
has got such bad side effects we never
decide to use it but we gotta know
there's a lot of people in the climate
community that hate mention of
geoengineering right
a lot of climate folks think that if
only we stopped driving suvs lived
simple lives etc we could just decide to
not have climate change
the trouble is climate change isn't a
decision
there's some very hard physics
so you can't just say oh we'll all go
green and it'll all be great and we
don't have to ever worry about
geoengineering
2050 is a date for various reasons that
gets focused on a lot so it's 20 50 are
we
are we okay what's your what's your if
you're betting
i think by 2050 we will have very
substantial temperature increase
and we will either have enormous
environmental consequences huge loss of
human life or both
and i think we really need to say what
are our alternatives
because with the crazy time scales of
this problem there's no other way
to bridge that gap
it was more fun eating the pizza
next up i head to the open seas
and then into the heart of seattle to
learn how to afford a house here
we bought it for 350 000
transformed the place and then we put it
back on sold it in four days for about
450 000.
[Music]
you